Bananen könnten für immer aus unseren
Regalen verschwinden und weight das ist
sogar schon mal passiert
was ist da los wie könnte man die Banane
retten und warum hat die EU etwas
dagegen genau diese Fragen beantworten
wir jetzt
[Musik]
dieser Pilz infiziert bananenstauten das
wiederum löst die sogenannte Panama
Krankheit aus und dann der sterben dann
die Bananenstauden Fusarium oxysporum
forma speziales cubense wird in der
wissenschaftlichen Fachliteratur kurz
genannt passender Name denn die fog
Variante tropical Race 4 bereitet sich
weltweit immer schneller aus die globale
banana Panama Pandemie umfasst bereits
29 Länder und die Bananensorten die wir
essen haben keine verteidigen dagegen
bisher denn die Wissenschaft kämpft
gerade um das Überleben der Bananen die
Schwäche der domestizierten Banane ist
ihre fehlende genetische Vielfalt je
mehr Unterschiede ist unter den
Individuen einer Art gibt desto höher
ist die Chance dass darunter Pflanzen
mit einer natürlichen Immunität bei sind
aber alle Kevin gestauten kevin ist
praktisch die einzige Bananen sollte die
man in Deutschland kaufen kann also all
diese Stauden auf den ganzen Plantagen
sind genetisch identisch
weil die Banane keine unerwünschten
Samen mehr hat muss die Pflanze nämlich
über Stecklinge vermehrt werden man
schneidet also einen neuen Trieb von
einer bestehenden Bananenstaude ab und
pflanzt ihn als neue Staude dass die
Früchte dann praktisch alle von der
gleichen Pflanze stammen sorgt für die
gleichbleibende Qualität es bedeutet
aber auch was eine Kevin gestaute
umbringt kann alle Kevin gestauten
umbringen und was sie wenigsten wissen
das ist schon mal passiert vor der heute
überall verbreiteten Kevin die Banane
hat eine andere Sorte die Herzen der
Bananen im port-länder erobert die grob
Michelle zu deutsch die Kamel das war
eine 500 Gramm schwere Banane die
weniger Druckstellen bekam und auch
besser geschmeckt haben soll als die
Kevin Tisch
bevor wir euch erklären was mit dem
dicken Michel passiert ist lass uns doch
mal schauen ob wir nicht neben den
Bananen auch noch eure Finanzen retten
können denn die Inflation ist für viele
gerade wie ein Pilz der das Konto
befällt vielleicht habt ihr in letzter
Zeit auch mal etwas teures gekauft und
das dann einfach per Ratenzahlung
finanziert das bedeutet dann aber auch
ihr macht de facto Schulden und das geht
leider schnell nach hinten los wenn es
nicht nur bei einem Kauf bleibt doch
dafür gibt's zum Glück auch den dicken
Michel der finanz-apps und zwar anifin
das ist eine All-in-One App mit der ihr
die Kontrolle über eure finanzielle
Zukunft wieder in den Griff bekommt und
hoffentlich schnell wieder schuldenfrei
werdet und eure Zinsen senken könnt wenn
ihr euch bei anifin anmeldet könnt ihr
auch in Kredit angeben den ja aktuell
abbezahlt anything schickt euch dann ein
Angebot wenn eure Zinsen gesenkt werden
können und ihr dadurch Geld sparen
würdet wenn ihr das Angebot dann annimmt
wird euer Kredit umgeschuldet das heißt
any Finn kümmert sich dann darum dass
euer alter Kredit abbezahlt wird und die
Zeit ab dann flexibel und zu besseren
Konditionen das Geld zurück mit dem Code
Faktor bekommt ihr dann übrigens noch
direkt 20 € von anifin geschenkt wenn
ihr eure Finanzen jetzt also schnell und
unkompliziert wieder in den Griff
bekommen wollt ladet euch anifin runter
und nutzt den Code Doktor oder geht über
den Link in der Videobeschreibung okay
wo waren wir stehen geblieben ach ja bei
Bananen und beim dicken Michel in der
ersten Hälfte des 20 Jahrhunderts viel
der Dicke Michel derselben Krankheit zum
Opfer die heute die Kevin dich bedroht
nur das ist damals an der fockvariante
tropical Race 1 lag tropical Race 4 gab
es damals noch nicht seit spätestens
1960 ist die Grand Michelle praktisch
nicht mehr auf dem Markt erhältlich also
tropical Race 4 ist für unsere Banane
tödlich der Pilz bereitet sich weltweit
aus eine Heilung gibt es nicht die Kevin
nicht könnte also dasselbe Schicksal
eilen wie ihre Vorgängerin nur 100 Jahre
später außerdem sind auch Bananensorten
betroffen die in einigen Ländern eine
Rolle einnehmen wie bei uns Kartoffeln
und Weizen
insgesamt droht also ein großer
wirtschaftlicher und vielleicht auch
humanitärer Schaden stellt sich
natürlich die super wichtige Frage was
kann man dagegen tun
[Musik]
Fock ist hartnäckig der Pilz lebt
geschützt im Boden weshalb er zum
Beispiel durch das Abrennen von
Plantagen nicht entfernt werden kann und
bis man ihn bemerkt hat er sich schon
weit verbreitet Landmanagement allein
ist also keine Lösung und auch chemische
Mittel also Fungizide sind ineffektiv
sobald der Pilz die Pflanze befallen hat
dann untersucht man noch die Behandlung
der Bananenstauden mit Bakterien die die
Pilzinfektion verhindern sollen die
Methode ist aber noch nicht ausgereift
und es bleibt die Frage wie sich das
Ausbringen von Bakterien in großem Stil
auf die umgebenden Ökosysteme auswirken
würde was bleibt ist die Banane selbst
resistent zu machen also ihre Gene zu
verändern da gibt es grundsätzlich
verschiedene Möglichkeiten zum Beispiel
die herkömmliche Kreuzung mit einer tf4
resistenten wildbanane das dauert aber
selbst bei normalen mehrjährigen
Pflanzen gerne mal Jahrzehnte weil
unsere Banane sich überhaupt nicht mit
Wildbahn ankreuzen kann wird es aber
noch schwieriger außerdem wieder
Nachkomme einer Kevin dush wildbananen
Kreuzung ja auch eine halbe wildbanane
und die schmecken nicht gut und sind
voller Kerne man müsste also die vielen
unerwünschten Eigenschaften erstmal
langwierig wieder herauszüchten
Jahrzehnte später hat man dann
vielleicht eventuell wieder eine schöne
Bananensorte aber nie wirklich eine
resistente Kevin de Banane statt der
Banane 50% der wildbananen Gene zu geben
und dann alle unerwünschten Gene wieder
heraus zu züchten könnte man auch
gezielt nur Gene in die Pflanze bringen
die sie resistent gegen Fock TR4 machen
und zwar mit Gentechnik für diese Studie
hier hat man z.B zwei verschiedene
transgende Kevin Bananen getestet die
eine hat ein einzelnes gehen von einem
Fadenwurm erhalten der mit dem Pilz im
Erdboden lebt die andere hatte einen
gehen von einer resistenten wildbanane
erhalten sie doch super aus aber jetzt
kommt der Haken die europäische
Gesetzgebung macht die Zulassung von
gentechnisch veränderten Lebensmitteln
so schwierig dass das
Zulassungsverfahren unwirtschaftlich
wird es könnte also gut sein dass es die
gerettete Kevin die Banane nie in unsere
Regale schafft
[Musik]
sollte fog tropical Race 4 wirklich die
gefährdeten Bananensorten ausrotten
drohen große wirtschaftliche Schäden und
vielleicht auch humanitäre Notstände
weil der Pilz so hartnäckig ist und die
Banane nur über Stecklinge vermehrt
werden kann ist dem Problem mit den
meisten Methoden praktisch nicht
beizukommen die in unseren Augen wohl
letzte Hoffnung scheint die
Gentechnologie zu sein die auch schon
gute Ergebnisse erzielt hat mit modernen
Gene editing-methoden macht man gezielte
und kleine Eingriffe ins Genom die
Änderungen sind so klein dass sie von
natürlichen Veränderungen nicht zu
unterscheiden sind
ältere Methoden lösen zufällige
Mutationen in großer Zahl aus und selbst
eine konventionelle Kreuzung ist ein
größerer Eingriff ins Erbgut mit
größeren zufallsanteil als Jean editing
trotzdem findet der EU Gerichtshof
bislang das Risiko von Jean editing sei
besonders groß aber es gibt jetzt einen
neuen Gesetzesentwurf nachdem Jean
editing Technologien wie z.B die
genschere Chris Park Hass nein von den
verschärften Regelungen für Gentechnik
ausgenommen werden könnten im Sommer
soll es dazu eine Entscheidung geben und
wir halten euch hier natürlich auf dem
laufenden abonniert also gerne den Kanal
hier um nichts zu verpassen und bleibt
immer neugierig euer Cedric
und jetzt werde ich eine Banane öffnen
wie man das nämlich richtig macht von
unten guten Appetit
ich behauptet